hey there ladies and gentlemen chris
waters here to welcome you to gamespots
now playing for madden nfl 15 sponsored
by best buy joining me over here is pro
madden player eric problem right eric uh
i'm gonna have to ask you to pause from
uh manhandling the minnesota offense and
uh say hello to the folks at home hey
how you guys doing uh tell us a little
bit about so whenever whenever i say
like pro player everyone wants to know
like what makes this guy pro like what
what's what's sort of the accolades give
us a little rundown um three-time madden
challenge champion
a mad nation champion what's matination
matt nation was the show that they ran
on espn2 oh that's right yeah the
reality yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so there was that and then the
madden challenge was the one that was
sponsored by ea best buy yeah so i won
that three times so those are the pretty
much the biggest you got some men chops
yeah well got some madden winnings under
your belt for sure very cool well uh
we're psyched to have you here to play
some madden nfl 15 and we're starting it
right off with a game we got the niners
versus the vikings you of course are
niners fan yeah big sign niners fan
excellent uh so it's been some good
years for you recently yeah it's got a
nice little resurgence it has been not
so much for the vikings though not so
much
yeah that's my fiance's team so i
figured i'll beat them oh really
but it's a message of love
all right well folks uh we're gonna be
taking your questions in the gamespot
chat and on twitch.tv gamespot
throughout the whole broadcast uh for
for us about madden and when i say us i
mean problem uh but let's get into the
game and we'll just we'll play a little
bit here you uh
you are running that defense against the
and adrian peterson has given you some
trouble yeah so you you get to see the
best run defense against
the best running back and you get to
kind of
get an idea of what's going to win out
for the year so
yeah so madden nfl 15 of course just
came out this week and so people are
just now getting their hands on it in
earnest and playing uh what's the kind
of as someone who you know
plays year year in year out and like is
really in tune with the subtleties the
first few days few weeks of playing
what's it like for you in terms of just
like
what do you try to do you're trying to
like calibrate and get an idea for what
all the tweaks are yeah i'm trying to
break down the game to see you know what
is the most successful against the past
what's most successful against the run
and then offensively
which routes are the best on offense uh
which running plays are the best so just
try to get an idea of what works in the
game and what doesn't because it changes
from year to year
and the balance changes is that
predominantly fueled by sort of
the players and the team and their
different ratings or is it also like
game systems that you you find are kind
of tweaked yeah both um so the player
ratings will dictate some of the stuff
that happens in the game but you want to
see what they added in the game as far
as animations and
sometimes you can get your receiver to
to jump
and you know catch the ball good and the
defender might not be able to defend it
as well some years another year because
like the jump animation is a certain way
yeah exactly exactly so it's it's
it just depends on you know how the game
plays and what new um features they
implement into the game as far as
strategy
and as far as animations i mean um as
far as those go so
so how is uh 15 sort of any early
observations about it i know you've only
been playing been able to crack into
this for a couple days so far yeah it's
in my opinion it's the best
defensive game that's been out in a
while um
that's just from you know a few
hours playing it
i feel like the defense is
real good on the game and it's
it has a lot of potential this year to
be a defensive game interesting yeah are
some years are a little more offensive a
little more defensive yeah and i think
um maybe having richard sherman on the
cover you know influenced them to yeah
to boost up the you know pass coverage
and stuff like that i bet a lot of focus
on defense in the last nfl season for
sure yeah for sure
all right taking the field now yes with
the offense yeah i'm on offense now this
is one of the new formations that they
have in the game
um it's bunch tight end out of the
pistol
so it it looks like it's going to be you
know
a decent formation on the game so i'm
going to mess around with it a little
bit and see what you got that receivers
loaded on that side yeah exactly get
some blocking for you or just sort of
flood that side for uh for past plays
sure and the niners have
three of the best um catching wide
receivers so
we need them to catch the ball they're
gonna hang on to it for the moment see
if i got it here
vernon davis
uh crabtree
uh
forgot all the other ones
that was one dude who was like on oh
philadelphia and then he came here crap
this is my nfl knowledge folks not 100
on point eric tay in the background
devoted niners fan shaking his head
problem being decent enough to just uh
chuckle with uh delight at my naivete
yeah so it would be bolden
i was thinking he came from the ravens
and then stevie johnson
from the bills so
bolden he always reminds me of uh
jerry maguire and the cuba gooding jr's
character in that game
oh man all right so on twitter just a
second ago
uh i tweeted about the game and i said
people are only welcome to come here and
cheer for the patriots because that's my
team oh okay cause i should have put the
pieces out there we'll get some patriots
action in a little bit uh we gotta we
got some we got some time ahead of us on
the street but uh
a lot of people in the gamespot chat not
approving of the patriots thanks seer
appreciate that yeah what's your team
the the giants
stupid giants
that's my sick burn to all people
the giants got got to brady you know
they did they really did and therefore i
can never forgive them yeah
yeah so they forced me to punt so now
they're back on offense and he got deal
with ap again
he's the best running back on the game
in my opinion still he's just
now does he
my heyday of playing football games was
about 10 years ago or maybe more uh and
yeah 20 years ago
uh you'd play games and then like you'd
run as like barry sanders or some
excellent running back and it would just
be broken like
just half back toss and like
like that's it you can score at will uh
do you i know that matt so much work
goes into madden nfl
so the franchise in terms of balancing
it so that you know no players is crazy
awesome but
you know if you got a running back like
ap on the other side you really have to
is he your sort of priority when you're
choosing plays to try to contain him
yeah he's real tough to stop um
especially because this year they have
you know a good set of receivers as well
and then their rookie quarterback is
good so
it kind of makes you respect the passing
game a little bit when you're going
against the vikings so it opens up you
know more for ap
and yeah it's not broken
in in the game like it maybe it used to
be on like the old games and stuff those
days are long behind us these guys are
way more on point yeah especially when
you're going against a good defense like
the niners who have
you know
one of the fastest set of linebackers in
the game
so they could kind of contain him a
little bit better and
their defensive line is
going to you know get by
minnesota's offensive line for the most
part you see right there with my
linebacker hit ap
um
probably not going to crush him in real
life like that yeah yeah
yeah he managed to make the player
uh
so
when you're playing like competitively
do you always stick with your niners
because you know them inside and out or
do you choose sort of the best team for
the situation if you know where your
opponent's choosing or
how do you how do you approach
competition so every year is is
different just how the game plays it
just depends on how the game is playing
so if it's a offensive year and you need
you know fast wide receivers you might
want to look at a team that has as fast
wide receivers so i never pick pick the
niners just because they're my favorite
team um look the last year that i won i
was
lucky enough to win with the niner so
that was that was cool to win with them
but previous years i had one with the
chargers and i had one with um
chargers yeah the cowboys unfortunately
yeah
you you're a little little embarrassed
about that
play with cowboys that made romo look
good better than what you know
he can make himself look
oh i got a buddy who would really love
you for that he's a huge cowboys fan and
it causes him no shortage of heartache
yeah romo uh we
we're going to kill the cowboys week one
too so
we get to play them
next week
when the season starts so is this is
that next week or two weeks is the labor
day weekend nfl kickoff i'm not google
that it might be the week after
that college kicks off this week oh
right yeah yeah
college are you much of a college
football fan or player at all do you
stay away from those well they don't
make the college game no more i know
that's right they stopped they stopped
making it yeah but um i follow college
football pretty heavily
don't really have a team though um
just kind of enjoy seeing ucla saturday
all football your sunday all football
yeah exactly yeah i love football
overall and um
college college has some exciting games
too so
it's cool to see yeah definitely this
year they got the
playoff little form i think it's the
fourth team
they have four team playoffs in um
college this year it's their first year
with the playoffs
system instead of the bcs so the bcs
which i you know i
i have like friends who are into college
football and what i get from that is
a whole lot of curmudgeonly
complaining about the bcs so yeah i'm
sure they'll be glad to see a little bit
of change
man
yeah they're about to score
defense here
focus a little bit check in the uh
chat here reminder folks that we are
taking any questions or comments uh
disparaging comments about the patriots
will not be entertained
obviously um but uh if you want to know
about the new game about problems uh
about competitive madden in general
about uh sort of player ratings we're
going to get into some player rating
stuff we're going to check out the new
stuff
new players this year some hot rookies
etc a little later in the stream and
then we're also going to see some new
modes in the game as well as diving into
madden ultimate team uh which i gather
something you like to play a lot
yesterdays and that's it's the most
popular game mode now for madden and
just a game mode where you get to create
your own team put put players from the
past with the new players put them all
on one team
on the previous year i had barry sanders
and steve young
on my on my team so
we'll get into that and build a team
from scratch right now see what we can
do with that
that sounds good well we might not end
up with the sanders but hopefully we'll
end up with something decent yeah
that'll be a little later on in the
stream but for now we're into the end of
the second half and uh
problem getting get having some problems
with the vikings here yeah they're uh
they're beating me right now 10-0 got a
score before half and uh we get the ball
back at half so
we'll be fine
you're not worried no you're feeling
confident here yeah it's just a
two-score game yeah we got plenty of
time yeah plenty of time
steely under pressure
all right we've got a question from we
got some questions coming in from folks
don mf johnson in the game spot chat is
wondering uh
for someone not too familiar with the
madden series of late uh is this do you
get an impression that this is like a
good
point of entry is this can is it sort of
require
a lot of knowledge about the series as
is to enjoy or do you can you get into
it without knowing too much do you think
yeah i think it's it's a perfect point
of entry this has been
probably one of the better games that
has been out lately i think that the
games play smooth and you know be a good
time to to start if you haven't already
and it's only going to get better from
here but yeah the game the game feels
great i mean graphics wise it's been
it's the best that it's ever been
and um
if you're looking to start yeah check it
out build your mutt team and you know
you you can pretty much put whoever you
want on your team and it's pretty cool
nice
that was a terrible pass yeah that was
thrown away it's like all right this is
not happening yeah i threw it away takes
on the run he throws up and run all the
time
all right b tons 28 i'm not sure if you
can know the answer to this one we'll
give it a shot anyways uh
so does this have downloadable like
rosters settings and playbooks
from other xbox one users like can you
share that stuff i'm not i'm not
entirely sure if you can share rosters
and
download them from other people
maybe someone in one of the chats
i think you can though let us know yeah
you can make a playbook and i think
people can download that you've been
able to do that in the past yeah you
have been last year there was there was
a way to do that um
you ever checked out anyone else's
playbook or put yours out there no i
haven't um checked out anybody else's so
when you go to tournaments
it's pretty much um
you have to use the the stock playbooks
that are in the game
you can't create oh you can't have your
own pick different place from different
playbooks so that yeah that they don't
allow you to do that so it kind of
behooves you to just stick with what's
in the game yeah
too comfortable
with anything tricky exactly exactly so
how many competitions like would you say
you play in in a given year in a given
year yeah um probably
it changed you know it got
lower over the years actually because
there used to be a lot more local
tournaments
and you're local to los angeles los
angeles yeah so there would be one every
month
in los angeles and then along with the
the sponsored ones by best buy or
whoever may be
so it changed over time but um as of
right now
probably about five i would say
throughout the year yeah it's kind of
it's kind of um low as far as
national tournaments go and stuff like
that so
how many people enter those tournaments
roughly a couple hundred yeah
yeah on on average it would be you know
100 to 200 people it just depends on
what year it was too because like last
year there was a tournament atlanta i
think they they got around 100 people so
it just depends on
the year and
get it the prize and stuff like that so
yeah how they can entice people all
right you were you're down to the wire
here i know i ran out of timeouts
he's out of timeouts yeah he's got to
take a shot
it's going deep
oh bolden
come on buddy get up for that i don't
know go go gadget arms or something
yeah we're going to try to throw in the
end zone again let's see rj madden won
in twitch chat boston in the house good
to see you enjoying the game problem i
don't know if that's someone you've
competed against or something like that
rg oh yeah rg rg actually he works with
ea rg madden r.g madden yeah
he works on the game yeah he's he used
to compete competitively with me as well
oh cool so i've known him for some years
now
and we're gonna take a shot here we're
gonna throw the davis
going to vd yeah
to the corner kaepernick give me a
chance he throws it out of bounds
give me a chance to catch it at least
yeah you got one more shot
now we're gonna take our three you know
you know we gotta score against the
computer at least you know get on the
board first half that stopped our first
try so one thing that they did do with
the game
the kicking meter that that little green
spot right there so that used to be
bigger
it got smaller it gets smaller now
it just depends on which kicker you have
so it's a lot harder to kick now
so um
that's one thing about that
you pull it back and then sort of thrust
it forward yeah you want to try it do i
want to try it so all right so you're
going to pull it back in that area
straight down nope nope
i pressed the wrong direction
and i flipped it super bad
oh wow
i am really sorry about that no when you
pull it back you have to flick it up i
didn't finish that that's why i didn't i
didn't i was trying to like aim left or
right i don't know why i did that i
don't know why i didn't just listen to
him yeah so you flick it down i owe you
three points that's my bad that's okay
put that on my tab
yeah so they did that which is which is
good i like that because in the previous
years you can make
60 yarders
almost every time with certain
characters yeah you shouldn't be able to
do that so that's not that's not the way
it goes yeah i liked how they um they
switched that up so that's that's cool
that they added that oh man
that
if we had the connect plugged in i would
get you guys a highlight of that
because that
was terrible
all right you gotta get time to put
together a proper drive now yeah we're
gonna
drive and then we'll get into like i
wanted to go over the gauntlet with some
people
yeah i don't know if anyone's familiar
with it in the chat but the gauntlet is
a new um mode that they have on here
it's part of the skills trainer
when you do different skills training um
challenges and you try to get the high
score between
you and your friends it's pretty cool
and it's been one of the things that
i've been playing messing around does it
help you get better at certain skills
like say kicking perhaps yeah the
kicking kicking's on there punting um
passing running yeah everything
everything that you need to do to play
the game is on there
cool so we'll play the second half here
in the
niners versus vikings match uh and then
we'll get into some more mad and stuff
here on game spots now playing for
madden nfl 15. quick reminder folks we
are sponsored by best buy for this
stream and best buy is offering some
deals for college students uh it's like
that time you're all back at school or
heading there so if you go there you
sign up with a edu mailing address deals
i don't know you don't know if you get a
deal on madden you probably can i don't
know if that's i don't know if that's
really educational but yeah you know you
can make some money at it yeah you can
case in point
eric problem right problem right on
twitter that's right with a w yeah
uh all right so
stupid
this is pretty bad to be losing the
computer like this
that's what i'm talking about the
defense is is way better
on the game now and um
as you can see like
the vikings their cornerbacks aren't
very good and they're jumping passes and
stuff like that so
yeah so just i mean it just depends also
what um
what difficulty you play on too i'm sure
if you
put it on the lower difficult just
depend on what you play on what what
your preference is so if you put it
lower yeah it's gonna be yeah the
defense will be lower and um
yeah but they've been playing here this
is on the all madden
um the highest one
that's what typically play on every year
um and that's what the tournaments are
for the most part so
um but yeah they they're they're
stopping the run good they're stopping
the pass good so i mean this is a
defensive workflow yeah exactly and this
is a defense that's not very good on the
game
for the most part and they're they're
playing good so that just tells you how
good the defense actually is on the game
especially if you're going all madden uh
so for those yeah gore
breaking one out yeah uh for those folks
of you who are wondering if this was a
good entry point
this is all madden difficulty all madden
difficulty is not a good entry point no
you can get i mean just like anything
else you get good at the game
like
still learning the game so you know once
once i get better at the game too
it'll be different as well so again once
you're not like talking to me the whole
time
yeah that shouldn't that shouldn't be a
big deal i mean
losing the computer pretty is pretty bad
yeah
do you rarely lose to the computer you
should never lose a computer no matter
what
absolutely not yeah they're giving me a
tough time do you do any live streaming
of madden like on your own on twitch or
anything yeah on twitch um i just
started this year on twitch actually
doing um some streaming
and it's uh it's it's cool and you get
people get to see you
play other people and they get to learn
some strategic stuff so
i like helping out giving people advice
on what what i like to do in the game
and um
what's good and what isn't good stuff
like that so yeah what's your uh twitch
username it's problem right with the
underscore between problem and right so
problem underscore right that's that's
what it is sounds right w-r-i-g-h-t yeah
w-r-a you got to give another try we
need three right here all right so tell
me the instructions i will leave my
hands off okay so when you pull it down
you're gonna go
up pretty much straight forward yeah
flick it straight forward
i didn't register it didn't register
yeah for whatever reason it didn't hey
it went straight towards the uprights
yeah improvement exactly yeah at least
it was straight
that's how his kick looks so maybe i did
it too quick i mean maybe my reflexes
are too fast
it could be it could be it could be
it could be that's what it is yeah all
right i owe you six now yeah no we're
still still still down here we need to
stop here
on patrick willis his face is all over
the train ads for fantasy football yeah
on my commute to work
actually that's a question i was going
to ask you uh do you in addition to
watching college football watching nfl
football playing a bunch of madden do
you do fantasy football leagues yeah i
play in fantasy football leagues like
how many you got going um
three three or four three maybe four
yeah
i haven't done two of the drafts yet
though they haven't start i think
they're later on this week actually
how about yourself you play no uh i
don't i watch football every sunday but
i feel like the fantasy thing would just
be down the rabbit hole too much oh yeah
there we go defensive plays oh we're
trying to bring it back in not quite
yeah fantasy is fun um i do one of the
auction have you heard of the auction
drafts i actually
might like that a little bit better than
the regular draft actually so you get a
certain amount of
um
points the ox
money pretty much against the auction
yeah and so you would like bid yeah you
bid on your players on a high profile
player yeah exactly exactly so that's
how that's how that those drafts are
extra strategy involved yeah because you
know you can overpay for a player you
can get ap but you might overpay for
them so it might not be worth it might
not be worth it all right so who were
some of your your solid fantasy picks
going in this year um this year
i like cordero patterson on the vikings
um i think he's gonna be really really
good this year
um i picked
late late in the draft i picked up uh
who was it
i forget who it was on on the patriots
one of one of their receivers i got late
in the draft i think he's going to be
all right um
other than that i i picked up kaepernick
in one of my leagues i think you know
it's kaepernick's year to win this super
bowl so
i think he's gonna he's gonna put him in
you think he's coming for it yeah i
think he's gonna get there again yeah i
think he is
they got a pretty good squad yeah they
do they got all the weapons he needs i
mean eric tay what do you think are they
gonna do it this year
the niners
yeah he's feeling calm
yeah they haven't they haven't looked
good at all haven't looked good in the
preseason but i mean it's pre-season
yeah what are you gonna do they're
hiding a lot of their stuff
being tricky
yeah we'll be fine did you pick up
julian edelman that might have been who
it was yeah that might have been someone
amendola no it wasn't amendola it might
have been edelman
and in lafell and then my receivers too
many i gotta get caught up on my rosters
this year i got julio jones in one of my
leagues and then um
he's my my best receiver and then in my
other league
i have uh
aj green so
feeling pretty good yeah yeah
hopefully we do well we won two of my
leagues last year so one of them i do
with the partner
he because he does the live draft and
last year i was at work during the live
draft so i let him do it so
yeah it's cool i like um
playing fantasy uh
it got it got a lot more popular as of
late so it's oh man it's huge yeah it is
it is
definitely a lot more people doing it i
mean the nfl certainly having a
popularity resurgence i feel like in the
past couple years yeah so uh yeah which
is pretty fun yeah and you can get uh
like nfl sunday ticket on on consoles
now which is how i like to watch it
because my patriots are out of market i
don't get to see them when i live 3 000
miles away
so you gotta gotta get them somehow all
right so this is this is one of the
things that they added this year
and it's just aaron throws they're
they'll make bad throws from time to
time and
right here he puts the ball pretty much
where no nobody can get it and in the
past
if you made a bad throw it's usually
just intercepted by the defense
but
now they have it to where you know he
puts it where no one can get it it's
just a bad throw and that's pretty much
what you see on sundays too you'll see
quarterbacks make miss their target we
miss their target yeah they don't always
put the ball on target no more so
this guy was wide open and he just made
a bad throw i tried to lead him and he
just overthrew it through but he also
didn't throw it right to another player
yeah exactly didn't throw it it's not
like
hey you missed your guy you got to hit
some other guy he's gonna be a defense
the defender yeah sometimes they just
yeah and i think that might have been
maybe something
in the past like maybe they couldn't
program it that way to where it had to
hit somebody so now they can make it
where you know they just make a bad
throw and it goes to absolutely no
nobody
yeah so you too can be as frustrated
exactly that i mean that's pretty much
going to do it right there we didn't we
didn't score so needed that one that's
all right yeah so
tough new defenses
uh we got a we got t dot gatsby in the
game swap or the twitch chat curious to
know
if he wants to like play you online is
there a way to do that maybe like get at
you on twitter or something like that
yeah i mean maybe we can do that or
today i mean tdot gapsy do you do you
have the game with you let us know
because maybe we could hook it up
yeah we could probably we could probably
do that we've also got archangel
lamenting
saying i wish i could say my redskins
were going to have a good season yeah
the redskins they're good on madden
though so hey there you go so that
that's what we'll do we'll just don't
watch the redskins games on sunday play
them in madden yeah yes
i mean rg3 is one of the better
quarterbacks in men so
he's 91 speed on the game so he'll
always be able to get you
those those yards scrambling and stuff
so he's one of the big factors on madden
he's one of the best players yeah is
that do you find that that uh you know
especially as the season goes on and
players sort of you know are on their
game or kind of off their game and do
you find that like
the madden reality diverges from the nfl
reality pretty quickly or yeah it does
and a lot of it has to do with you know
madden
the best characteristics are your speed
so if you want to go for the fast
players fast teams
um
and that's that's one of the reasons why
rg3 separates himself and madden
but not so much in real life i mean in
the real game yeah so well archangel
also says his knee is still in one piece
in the virtual world
yeah exactly that doesn't come to come
into effect he does have an injury
rating though in madden oh yeah and
we'll look at that actually i'm
interested to see what it is so when you
have a lower injury rating
you're more prone to getting injured in
the game so it might be lower i mean
we'll check to see what his rating is
we'll look at the rosters after this
game right here
and see some of the new transactions and
stuff like that some of the the new
rookies that they have on the game they
just punted to the one inside the one
yeah
oh my goodness i thought it was out of
the end zone but no they got it right
yeah
greatest punt in the history of punts
that ball looks like it's
where is that that's that's crazy the
ball is looks like it's inside the goal
in a tight spot yeah
all we need is an 18-point play i know
historically they're a real solid
punters franchise and uh
they had a little punter uh turnover i
feel like last season with uh
chris warcraft on twitter i forget his
actual full name
yeah that's him what happened what
happened oh uh he got let go by them and
then was
saying it was because he was like a real
outspoken kind of on social and
political issues yeah i think i did read
about that yeah that was recently right
yeah i think that was just last season
yeah
i'm not sure what his
professional status is now or what the
vikings actual punter status didn't he
sue the team or or something like that
yeah that sounds all right are you going
come on get it
nice
that's one of those
that's one of the
rookies on our team yeah
hyde yeah yeah we just drafted him this
year he's
he's not really a madden player when i
say that i mean like
fast he's not fast he's actually really
slow for a running back so
i mean not the kind of guy you would
necessarily pick yeah exactly exactly
exactly he wouldn't be my first round
pick in a fantasy draft basically but he
looks good and real life looks like he's
going to be
be tough to tackle for sure do you ever
get do you ever find yourself uh
watching games and like getting mad at
people that they're not as fast as they
are in madden no like you should be
making that run right yeah exactly no i
i could separate it pretty well
as far as you just wanted to take that
guy into the pen zone with you there we
go trying to get hide some points yeah
i'm trying to get hide in this only just
he deserves it for that catch he made
that was that was a big time play
he is not a madden player
oh so close
at least i wasn't responsible for that
one because i have been responsible for
some gaps in this game he just dropped
the ball so they're
you can see the they're reviewing i
don't know what they're reviewing he's
pretty much standing up
yeah he is definitely
just got that shoulder
vikings lime and just got that shoulder
in there yeah uh there's a question a
little while back actually i forgot who
asked it in the twitch chat about
controlling the offensive line
and uh like is that something you do
much do you have any tips for sort of
how to handle the offensive line or you
just kind of let it let them do their
thing yeah i let them
they gave me the ball back
i don't know how they over overturned
that
that's pretty crazy um what
was it like maybe they stopped this
forward progress or so i have no clue
what would happen right there rgb maybe
argent madden could help me out with
that yeah
what happened man rg madden yeah with
the alaska
take it
and give it to hyde yeah i had to bring
in you know gore for the situation
he's got it
oh there we go
all right we got on the board
last second there it is
excellence
what was it what was the question oh it
was about the offensive line and kind of
oh okay controller any way to sort of
you know
finagle them a little bit control them a
little bit to give you a little bit of
an edge no you you don't want to i mean
i don't even know if you can i know in
previous years you could do that but you
don't you don't typically want to play
on your alignment
rather just a computer but you can um
shift your your offensive line to
protect one way or another left right or
um
you could aggressive block so there's
different ways that that's kind of like
call at the line of scrimmage yeah right
exactly
so you you would use the lb and then
left right up or down to to shift them
which way you want them to go when the
balls snap
they can pretty much
you want to use that when you're running
the ball and even for pat for pass
protection
it's really good
if you know blitz is coming from the
right to have them shift to the right so
protect the right side so
when you read the defense exactly
exactly so if you see a defense is
stacked on the right side you want them
to to protect the right side there's
more guys over there on that side yeah
exactly what you're more guys over there
on that side yeah it's a lot more um in
depth now than it used to be you never
used to be able to do that on the old
games and
it's pretty it's pretty crazy how
advanced it is now so many different
things you can do when you're playing
coaches have mock turtlenecks now
yeah exactly so all right so that was a
look at the game in action we'll get
into another game a little in a little
bit but let's go poke around a little
bit in the uh the sort of rosters and
see
take a look at some some rankings some
updated players are there any do you
think that will be controversial or
anything like that let's let's get into
it yeah we'll look at um some of the new
rookies that are in the game
and the popular teams like the niners
and seahawks
and then you have some of the sleeper
teams who i think are going to be good
on the game like the steelers i think
the steelers are going to be one of the
best teams you're going to be a solid
madden team yeah on the game so
to start i mean we'll look at uh
some of the rookies like
bortles was the first quarterback
drafted so
he's on the jack he has bad support and
cast i mean he's decent speed 73
and then we'll look at some of his
passing attributes
he has
above average throwing power yeah and
then accuracy he's good he's pretty much
he's good across the board he's he's
good for a rookie
and um
so if you got him in like
ultimate team you might not be upset but
you probably don't want to play the jazz
yeah you're not gonna play with the jags
yeah they don't have enough weapons like
gearhearts are starting running back you
would probably play todman though cause
he's 94 speed and
you would you would look at these two
him and dinard robinson to see
who has the better running stats as far
as like carry goes
they're both pretty they're both pretty
even
yeah catching they're even so it would
just be between those two i mean
gearheart's too slow to play in madden
in my opinion and then his receivers are
not very good they're they're they're
okay they're just not
i don't think they're just not not
enough talent i think you're gonna
offend them personally you know
it's okay you can say what you really
think
so another quarterback that
probably the most popular yeah
johnny football so
he's 82 speed so that's that's very good
um
what's your like
what's your cutoff for just unacceptable
speed like 70s 70 speed is good enough
to move around yeah you don't want to
have anything lower really yeah and
that's what's crazy about the game
because
you can't use this guy if if you're
looking for the mobile and he's
arguably one of the best quarterbacks of
all time he's really good he just can't
move he can't move so it's hard when
someone's blitzing you to get out of the
pocket and um does that actually make
him makes him a madden liability yeah it
makes him a liability in that sense
passing the ball you know he's gonna
pass the ball just as good as anybody
but that's the thing
it's a bigger cutoff with the speed
the speed differentials are so much i
mean
kaepernick could make almost every throw
that manning could make on the game but
speed i'm going to go with kaepernick
yeah exactly
so we got manziel and then
yeah those are the rookie quarter
quarterbacks and then we'll go to the
number one overall pick in the draft
jadavion clowney and his ratings for
rookie are crazy he's
just started his 88 speed
and
they have him as right outside
linebacker
92 acceleration
and then his hip power and and tackling
and everything else should be
should be good
95 hit power so
ninety four is a big number yeah he
could force those fumbles when you hit
sick somebody he has this
a better chance to force those big hits
and that's when they they fumble us when
offense fumbles so would you if you were
playing as the texans would you select
him as your
as your playable as who you control
pretty much all the time um i would
actually let him pass rush so i'd let
him in um jj watt who's also
99 overall i'll let i'd let them just
rush the passer yeah and i'd probably
play on cushion
who's also good on the game so
i would want um the computer to maximize
clowney and watt as pass rushers because
if you can get a good pass rush on
somebody then that's going to affect
them overall it's going to create a lot
of problems for them yeah they've that's
probably one of the best duos on the
game him and uh what
do you know ryan shazier yeah he's on
the steelers he's also
generally maxful wants to see some ryan
shazier stats yeah
great rookie right here um
steelers first first round pick and he's
92 speed
like i said that's
that's great for linebackers you're
going to typically see um
between 80 and
85 for the most part that's that's
standard but when you see 92 you're
you're way above average and
he has everything too i i believe as far
as hitting and that goes 97 jump so if
you need him if he's underneath
to tip down a ball he could get up there
and get it for you
his tackle's good good enough 82 and
then he has that 91 hit power county was
95 but
clowney was you know number one pick in
the draft so as you can see shay's here
isn't isn't that far off noodle legs
said they should make a special hit for
clowney where he blows the helmet off
the runner and they fumble yeah i know
he's done that he already did that in
the nfl preseason yeah that's crazy and
this is one of my one of my sleeper
teams this year the steelers yeah you
were mentioning that why would sit well
so why do you say that i just think that
they're good at every position so you
have big ben throwing the ball and then
he's at that cut-off speed he's he's
fast enough to get out of there
and then oh they got a man blount over
there yeah yeah
patriot
so archer
98 speed
he's he's
that's kind of bonkers yeah he's like a
baby jamal charles out here and he he's
good on the game so i put him in and um
the receivers are good they all can
catch for the most part
and then you got
a good defense um
chazier is someone that you saw
yeah timmins is still on the team
jarvis jones is cool
the corners are
both both good like taylor and cortez
allen and then their safeties are good
mike mitchell from the panthers
and then troy palamalu so they're
they're just good at every position
there's no really weak point for them
yeah yeah they're very good uh speaking
of weak points we're going to take a
look at that rg3 injury rating oh yeah
yeah let's check let's take that and
then we have a few requests here in the
chat for uh for
folks wanting to see their their own uh
choice players so we'll take those real
quick rg3 91 speed
i believe this is the highest speed of
any quarterback yeah him and prior are
the highest so
he's the fastest quarterback on the game
and then we oops let's go let's go look
at his his passing is good
pro power he's 93
and all his accuracy
short short throw medium are good
besides deep throw six you throw really
yeah
yeah deep throws bad
let's look at that injury
83.
and that that's that should be i mean
that's on the low side the highest the
higher it is is that more injury
resistance yes okay so the lower it is
the the more prone they are to injury
exactly so
just sorting by um
the injury rating you see bradford is 82
and then you have griffin
83.
and that's is that like the lowest area
for i mean we're looking into all nfl
yeah we're looking at all nfl qb's
they're pretty low i mean
yeah not looking good mikey yeah it
seems like any time vic gets hit he gets
hurt on the game and all right
jimmy garoppolo okay grapple garoppolo
yeah patriots these are probably actual
players i don't actually recognize a lot
yeah he's on your team
my patriots roster is
it's changing a lot this year yeah so
he's a little bit more mobile than than
brady
um
but look at some of his passing
attributes
89 throw power that's that's serviceable
his accuracy
in general is 76
but he has everything like as far as
short 84 medium 80 deep curl 71 so he
he's he's good oh he's good overall i
mean
he wouldn't play on this team
you got brady so you you don't need him
you'd rather you'd rather use brady but
garoppolo is pretty even though brady
can't really hustle that much yeah but
69 speed i mean it's gonna make a little
bit of a difference but you'd rather go
with brady's arm over his arm many days
for sure
all right uh we've got brandon cooks
saints rookie wide receiver yeah brandon
cooks very good player um very fast
95 speed
see here acceleration and agility both
are 96 so once he catches it you know he
has he can get into his moves and his
cuts a lot faster than
the average player 92 elusiveness
ball carrier vision 87 yeah so he's he
has all the moves um juke move 94
spin move 84. so after the catch i'm
sure he's he's real tough to tackle
his catching's 86 and his catching
traffic's 85 so
i mean he he's good his route running is
not that good which is 76 but
overall he's he's going to be a good
player and the saints are another team
that are real good on the game this year
yeah they're really good
pretty much all around looks like we've
got some folks interested in new orleans
in the chat here oh yeah we'll go
through it
all right you want to go through it real
quick yeah sure so bri everyone knows
brees one of the best quarterbacks in
the league this is their weakest point
though so if you're a runner
and you run the ball a lot you're going
to struggle with this team because
they're all just
average at best and they're below
average speed so
they can't even make it up with their
speed
receiving wise they're good though so
you have
a couple 95 speeds you have colston
still
you have the best tight end on the game
jimmy graham
the offensive line is average
um
d-line is okay and then the linebackers
are all pretty pretty decent you have
harrelson and lofton and their corners
are good they got champ bailey in the
off season
champ bailey he also picked up jerry's
bird from uh the bills
96 overall so he's a good player and
then their second year safety for carl
is good so
uh saints are real good they're they're
probably
they're for sure a top ten team i don't
know where i would rank them in the ten
but they're for sure top ten nice uh
we're looking at justin gilbert
justin gilbert is a corner
what's what team is gilbert on what does
that what yeah no he's right here what's
justin i wasn't sure if this was this
was a team he was on so he's on the
browns
the rookie he's he's good 94 speed
so when you're looking at um defensive
players and a rating that does i feel
always affected the game was awareness
and you see right here 59 awareness that
that might not be a good rating to have
yeah not so much so what do you just in
terms of like their position on the ball
or the
like sort of yeah so the way getting to
where to play yeah to where they get in
position to make a play
or they're
you know if they're running the ball
just to know that you know i need to go
stop i need to be able to stop that run
so he won't put him the computer won't
put himself in position
a lot of the times when they have lower
awareness so that that's not a good
rating to have but let's look at some of
his uh other ratings catch is good 75
catch for a defensive player is good
some receivers don't have that
um
look at his coverage ratings
so you're hitting like a few specific
ratings per position that you are sort
of prioritizing as like the main
indicators of
a player sort of their general effect
yes in the game yeah you want so there's
i mean
for cornerbacks you're not going to look
at his pass rushing every position has
certain ratings you want to look at sure
to see if they're good going to be a
good player or not he doesn't need
finesse moves yeah exactly but his man
coverage and zone covers are both good
mid-80s so that's good for a rookie it's
good for any cornerback in the game so
his press is only 76 but you know that
that's not that bad so he'll he'll be a
good player on the game and he's he's
going to be tested a lot if you use the
browns because he's opposite of
arguably one of the best corners in the
game hayden so
you know people are going to throw at
gilbert a lot yeah hopefully that
awareness awareness doesn't come in the
factory that much
all right let's check out we've got only
one or two more requests here bishop
sankey bishop titans rookie running back
yeah titans
so
let's see here
89 speed um
let's see some of his russian attributes
he's 91 in acceleration and agility
which is really good
we'll check his carry because
yeah 81 is good enough you don't need
any of that gore
goal line yeah fumbling yeah exactly how
to hide yeah
juke move 92 he's good he's not chris
johnson
which is you know who they lost
thank you sankey will be good on the
game
um
you could probably start him actually of
the running backs
yeah i'd probably start sankey i mean
all right well let's do uh one more
request and then tdot gatsby says let's
do it big homie okay uh so gatsby why
don't you
uh
send
what's the best way for her to get in
touch with us well send your uh whatever
you call it no i might be able to just
send him mine and i could play him okay
so we'll do it that way because we still
got to go over some of the other yeah
we've got a little bit but send a
request you see the name right there up
in the top right corner it's riverdogs
tdot gatsby send us a little thing
and uh we've got a request from wernstar
for sammy watkins okay yeah he's one of
the better rookies on the game
um rookie wide receiver from the bills
there is watkins
so he comes into the game 80 overall so
that's that's good already
93 speed
95 acceleration 95 agility
so he's he's he's very good
already i mean just off those we'll take
a look at his catching
88 catch
77 catching traffic 87 spectacular kids
so watkins is very good one of the best
rookies overall on the game
and
the bills again that's another team
that's a sleeper team and he's a big
part of it
he's probably their best receiver on the
team
um
that was a pretty good super team yeah
bill's bill's very good they have a
mobile quarterback in ej manuel
and spiller's one of the best running
backs on the game he's fast elusive
he has all the juke moves and stuff like
that
their defense their front seven is one
of the best on here with led by mario
williams
and then they have two big defensive
tackles that are both rated very high 95
and 91 so yeah the bills are another
super team i'd say them and the steelers
are probably my two sleeper teams this
year excellent all right we'll do one
last request here and uh that's gonna be
the sean mccoy
michelle mccoy how are you holding up
mccoy
one of the best on the game overall so
97 overall mm-hmm
as you can see with running we'll take a
look at just running backs in general
how he compares with
you they have him as the third as a
third best running back in the game i
mean him and charles are tied but we'll
we can look at how they all compare to
each other since
mccoy you have to compare him to charles
and peterson so he's the slowest of the
three
but he has the most agility 99 agility
98 acceleration
um let's see some of the other ones 99
elusiveness wow there's a lot of 99s
from mccoy 99 ball carrier vision yeah
no you see stiff arm ap has that 96
stiff arm if you look a little bit lower
you got marshawn lynch with the 99 stiff
arm so
um spin move mccoy again 96 then he has
99 juke move
um 96 carry
yeah mccoy is one of the best backs on
the game probably
he probably is the best back i mean when
you take in catching into consideration
i would say him or charles sure because
charles is also 85 catch so
that's one thing that ap does lack and
they said that this year supposedly
north turner is going to have
ap catching a lot more passes so
hopefully that uh that madden catch
rating for ap goes up if it does then
you know he might be over 99 overall so
what would you say to someone using
madden ratings as like a guide for their
fantasy football picking
um you could you could get you know some
of the some of your stuff from there
maybe catching i guess to see if someone
could catch the ball like if you weren't
familiar with um
if it's a ppr league and you need a
running back that catches the ball
and you go here and you look at okay
marshawn lynch 67 cash he might not get
you some you could just use that and say
you know he's not going to give you that
many receptions probably you know that
typically the guys with the higher catch
is because they're throwing to them a
lot more and that's what you see here
these three guys they all get a lot of
passes out of the backfield charles
mccoy and forte
and then it drops off gore's catch is a
little bit low i mean gloria
gorham gore should have a better catch
than 66 in my opinion but you know
i'm a homer a little bit yeah you might
have a little bit of a bias working for
you yeah exactly so all right well let's
uh go check out some of the new uh sort
of gauntlet stuff here uh just a
reminder folks you're watching game
spots now playing for madden nfl 15
sponsored by best buy it's offering some
college deals for kids getting you all
students getting back into college these
days uh you can check them out over
there and uh we are here with eric
problem right professional madden player
uh
champion of many madden
tournaments
winner of much madden glory
and we're taking your questions uh
throughout the game throughout the
stream on the gamespot chat or on
twitch.tv slash gamespot
uh so now what are we checking out here
we're gonna look at um it's actually a
mode inside of skills trainer and it's
called gauntlet so skills trainer
it focuses on certain aspects of the
game and getting you better at those
skills so
it has passing challenges russian
challenges
um tackling journals
coverage drills so it has everything but
the gauntlet combines them all in one
which is right here you select it's all
the way to the right so you can target
specific uh disciplines if you want but
then you can go to the gauntlet to just
do the whole thing yeah and the
gauntlet's gonna throw random ones at
you and you if as you complete them and
you're successful it tallies them up in
the top right hand corner
and pretty much you want to get the
highest score of all your friends it
keeps track online it tells you who's
doing what who has the highest score
currently is it just about consecutive
challenge completion no so it's just a
total so you get five lives no as you if
you fail one of the challenges
you lose alive and you retry so you
might lose all your lives on one
challenge
you might all right you know
you might complete 20 in a row and then
lose them all in one so it just depends
so this first it tells you right here
every rep is different and
after five fails you're turn in so we'll
we'll see what the first one is
so it tells you it gives you the the
directions on what to do so run the
stick pass concept and complete a pass
so you look at the routes and you just
got to complete the pass to whoever's
open
so that'll be successful and it gets
harder as it goes that was the easy one
sure um
here's one of this you got to make this
easy field goal yes this is my time all
right that's what i was trying to do
before it was aim on the first yeah
right there so it's a game with the left
stick we got the aim pretty much on
point so when you bring it when you
bring it down you're going to see the
meter go down and then you're going to
see it go up and then you just flick it
when it gets to its highest point to its
highest point yeah all right so i'm
watching the meter
see where it was green up there that's
when you went terrible yeah that's when
you want to flick it you get to try
again i'm going to try it's only that's
only i'm going to get this field goal
that's only one live right it's clapping
in the back
so you got to aim it first okay
here we go all right
all right
there you go yeah i feel pretty good
about that one yeah that'll go in it
yeah
where's the clapping now production
booth
nerds you guys suck
oh
i won't call it redemption but i will
call it not total embarrassment yeah and
that's really what else can one man hope
for
what is going on right now there's like
some coaches on the field yeah so this
is one of the tackle drills and one of
the linemen drills you have to get past
the lineman and get to the quarterback
so they have a bunch of drills this is
the linebacker one
and you want to just
get to them and tackle with a and i
missed i missed them right there um
so yeah that they go over everything and
just like like we said like with the
kicking you can practice your kicking on
here and it'll get harder as it goes
as as you go get deeper into the gun
yeah they get harder throw at you yeah
this is the one that you saw earlier
with the
it's in
a boss yeah every fifth level you go
against a boss that's what they call it
so this one you're kicking into
a hurricane
a hurricane win yeah what are you trying
to do you're getting a 112 yard field
goal
yeah so you did it you have the wind
behind you
yeah all right get a little they get a
little creative with it that's good
it's a cool cool mode that they added on
here
i think a lot of people will like this
and you get better at certain things you
get better at the at each individual
skill that they have on here
and you can use these um
like this was the level it was called
levels um
the concept so
you get to see how it works against the
defense and then when you're picking
your plays in the game you could search
for plays that have that same concept
have that same kind of absolutely
you might might be a way to like
recognize new plays
uh you know learn some of the
terminology
stuff like that
and because it's
because it's kind of random what they're
throwing at you
you might you know
you might learn stuff that you've never
even you know exactly that you never
knew these concepts existed or what the
reason was and this is another boss
right here this is a pretty cool one you
got to follow your blockers up the field
and you'll see they just crushed the
defense right here
nice
super powered kick return team yeah
they're all right there with you
brady's behind me
yeah brady's even there
oh man nice back the cute quarterback
and then another new feature that they
added on here was the way that you rush
the passer
so they have it um
to where a and x they do different moves
now finesse move and power move yeah i
notice a prompt came up is that kind of
like a a quick time
it's a guide yeah and that's not in when
you're playing someone head-to-head that
won't be there
but um when you're in the gauntlet it's
it's pretty much a god
regardless just trying to get everybody
better
and they can use these
these little um prompts to to help them
complete these challenges
this one we just had to score on that
play have you uh
spent some time with the gauntlet in the
past couple days yeah i've played it a
little bit where did you where'd you get
up to my highest score i think was 21 22
somewhere around there
one of my friends got a 35 i believe
it's pretty hard yeah it's pretty tough
to get once you get into the higher
levels they have a few things that are
pretty challenging
all right let's check out we'll see the
next boss
yeah the next boss
maybe get check out some ultimate team
yeah yeah we'll take a look at some
ultimate team uh so this one's the
running back one
just gotta do some open field
yeah they could get by long right there
you can do it
they gotta ridley go yeah
go go go go go
yeah we'll take a look at all the crowd
noise by the way they're cheering for
you
all right cool uh yeah let's take a look
at some uh
some some of the old
mutt okay yeah we're getting we'll get
into the mud right i know you really
want to keep this going no this is this
is the last one let's score this is the
last one right there that tackle
yeah we'll take a look at mutton
building the team from scratch and some
of the new um
things that they haven't mut as far as
collections go and stuff like that
so this ultimate team stuff i mean
obviously it's it's huge in fifa it's
huge and madden uh this what would you
say you know
why is it so appealing for you
i think it's to me for me personally
yeah it's
because i could put all different niners
from different areas on one team oh
really make that yeah i make a niners
powerhouse yeah i make a niner team i
have
i got steve young
um jerry rice
and kaepernick's my backup uh montana
disrespect montana i put him as my
backup but yeah so
i mean steve young and that's that's the
thing steve young is he's got a faster
quarterback than montana so he's gonna
have all the games yeah exactly that's
that's that's madden so when you when
you start with the mutt you you choose
your uniform so so since it's yours
we're going to go with the patriots yeah
definitely
yeah the whole elvis face or whatever
they called it yeah and then you go
through your team style so you have a
bunch of different styles that you could
pick
um and this will help with your building
your team's chemistry
so when you get players their cards they
have different chemistries on them okay
and it might be a short pass it might
say long past so as you build that it
builds your team's chemistry and when it
gets to a certain level it just makes
your team it builds boosts their
attributes for those um
for those particular attributes that are
in your team style so for for this one
we'll just use short pass and it tells
you which attributes sounds good that
you build you build pass block
no your offensive line perform forms
better pocket and then catching traffic
so when you throw
those balls in and into traffic your
receiver will come down with it more
often than not
sounds like a good patriots game plan
yeah that's that's brady right there
so
these are a couple of the things
i mean if you
don't have to go through yeah we want to
go through all the basic stuff okay uh
let me just sort of get started here
but only if they're in your lineup
yeah so johnny manziel so this is these
are some of the players that you get
when you pick the short pass and you
want manziel to start
i mean he's one of the better players
you can get to start so
you look at his attributes on here 80
speed
um
throwing accuracy is up so everything
he's good he's a good starting
quarterback in the beginning of mutt
and this year they they focused on
making the players
a lot lower rated than they have been in
the past oh really yeah because on mutt
you'll see teams with all 99 overall
players and
they're making it harder to get to that
point so okay so in the beginning you're
going to see a lot lower the ratings of
the players that's a there's a global
rating so like johnny manziel only has
one rating in madden nfl 15. yeah
but they're just taking those higher
players those 99s of richard sherman's
and whatnot and making them much more
rare no so manziel in the regular game
he has his whatever whatever
77's okay so in mutt though they make
different versions of the card of the
johnny manziel card so oh so you can get
a couple different johnnies yeah so that
johnny right there is 70. but later on
they'll release a johnny that's 99 or
95 and he might be 95 speed as well so
but that'll be a much rarer yeah exactly
harder to get all right and to get him
you can do a couple of different things
um
you can get them in a pack with your
opening packs like the pro packs that
they offer
or you can go on the auction block
let's see where that's at
oh this is just a store
there's a thing they have it's called
the auction block and people they put
their cars on there
and you you pretty much bid on it with
your coins with your coins yeah so you
can see how much everyone's going so
coins you coins are the currency you
earn in game points are the currency you
purchase exactly with your credit card
and then right and sort of get more
packs that way right it tells you like
for the pro pack right here
7 500 uh
coins or 150 points and you can see
um it tells you it's like if you were to
purchase it how much
what the distribution is yeah exactly
how much it let's see
see it tells you how much you get for
each amount we could we could spend some
bucks here if you want but it's not like
75 yeah yeah like if you want to spend
20 likes yeah i think 20 is a good way
to start your team okay so if you want
if we can do that and just yeah you see
what we get in some packs and we'll open
up a few packs and see what we get in
here all right so we'll do that go ahead
and do that let's switch the feed to uh
just not just to us real quick
can you do that easily
i'm not sure what it's going to show
probably my credit card information but
like no it doesn't show it it doesn't
show but we could switch it anyway just
in case all right i'm pretty sure it
doesn't though
don't you leave me a [ __ ]
i don't need to get identity thieves
yeah yeah it's funny because on twitch
when when i purchase it um twits
automatically pauses the stream when you
do that yeah it's pretty cool feature
they have on there
they can read like when you're going
into this particular yeah exactly yeah
okay yeah they pause it so
that will not happen here
because we are doing a different thing
uh
they're gonna try to switch it up real
quick
if possible uh and then we're gonna go
ahead and there we go all right by the
way let's do it
okay yeah because they're just gonna get
the 15 pro pack bundle which is
20 from the store and you get 15 packs
and
i suggest if you're starting a team
that's that's what you do and um
we'll go ahead and go with that
that sounds good yeah yeah let's do it
i think it just goes through your face
it's going to have my your promotion
already logged in there
yes
sure
confirm confirm
oh you already have some
i got some leftovers
i got some leftover books
yeah that one's good just choose that
uh yeah perfect
charge me immediately
cool
folks you are watching the
game spots now playing madden nfl 15
live stream we're playing some madden
ultimate team here with eric problem
right i'm chris waters and uh we have
just purchased some pro packs we're
gonna see what kind of players we got so
to fill out my my madden ultimate team
yeah we're gonna open up a few packs um
let's see here
so we have two if you look in the
switchback yeah yeah they'll switch back
okay all right we're good guys
let's see that gameplay now
it's coming it's coming folks okay we're
good so
we just purchased 2 200 points so we can
buy the
15 pro packs
and i suggest if you're like like i said
if you're starting a team and you want
to
have a decent team i suggest you you buy
the bundle right off right off the bat
just to get some decent i know you're
going to get something decent in there
you know unless you know you're just
unlucky
unless you're really really unlocked
yeah exactly so when you open the packs
it goes through that little screen right
there um
so you have
a coach card
vince williams 69 overall i mean he's
not he's going to be better than what
you start with is that a jersey i can
have yeah jerseys yeah so when you're
playing you could mix and match whatever
jersey you want okay you could play with
um and same with playbooks you have to
get your playbooks through here too so
ted ginn was the card the gold card that
i got in here on this one so every pack
is going to have one card that's gold or
elite
and
see
he's 94 speed
he's i can use him on kick return and
stuff so he's going to be my starting
receiver as of now
uh we have john harbaugh's offense for
the ravens
yeah it's too shabby is that just like
the i mean is it the whole like
offensive line no the offensive playbook
oh the playbook okay all the plays that
you that you use will be from there
um
and
we've got a decent left in and then
tolzine will be our our starting
quarterback for now actually no we got
manziel so yeah we got manzo
yeah so we're good so that was the first
pack
we'll open up another one here
look at gabe jackson just lounging
exactly stretching out those glutes yeah
so you get um stadium cards too so if
you want to play in a certain stadium
one game or
for multiple games you can just can't
call it mile high anymore i know i guess
sports authority i didn't even know that
they switched it so this is
still probably call it mile high yeah
yeah this is a
the the gold card that that is in this
pack right here is this aaron anders
henderson promote him to starting major
league baseball
let's see here
good
really it's been and so then you're just
sort of comparing them against what
you've already got you're sort of
because you you start with you when you
start do you have a default lineup you
don't have to wait until you get you
know
no you have a lineup no you already have
a line up yeah and they're all um
so you can compare them to your other
halfbacks on your team and you have
sheets
sheets is your current and then it tells
you right here it's pretty cool
and this is a new one here it runs down
their height and then their speed and
some of their key attributes so you can
see
demps will be the better option
i mean just off speed 95 speed demps is
going to be your guy to go to so
um you can promote him as a starter for
now until we get somebody better
and then they have um
options to you can quick sell him and
get coins okay or you can auction
yeah exactly
uh mr sticky buns asking in the chat is
this guy new to mutt uh this guy yes
this guy no
so we're just taking a quick look at uh
at how it's shaping up here uh is
speaking of you know so for folks who
aren't new
to ultimate team what
what are the sort of most significant
tweaks this year around well the way you
can complete your collections this year
it's a lot easier
um
you just click add to set and it'll
add him to your collection so
collections are
um a set of cards that allows you to
unlock
a card that might be like 99 overall for
instance so if you get certain cards and
put them all in this collection it'll
give you
like a
yeah a beast card and and it could be
you know it could be that 99 tom brady
so you got to get these cards and the
way that you get them some of them are
rare some of them are low rated but
they're rare in the game so
you might need a guy that's that guy
that was lounging you might need him for
a collection and only you know even if
he's a low-rated dude yeah and only a
certain amount of people will have him
so you they're going to
bump up
yeah they bump up the price because they
know
that it's a rare car exactly so
yeah you'll come across stuff like that
um but yeah i mean overall the interface
is good on mutt and
you know it's going to be it's going to
be a good fun year for mutton
i'm building i'm currently building my
team as well at home so
um i've got cavs shaping up cam newton's
my quarterback right now he's he's good
he's real solid on the game
he's real good he's i think he's like a
top three quarterback as of now on mutt
um this guy was our best card
got that 49ers offense which did not
avail us in the
kickoff game yeah so right here we got
um demarcus ware in this pack but we got
the ghost version of demarcus yeah he
can't be seen yeah exactly and therefore
that's funny what's that about why i
don't picture it out there i don't know
i don't know if that's
he didn't approve his image or something
i don't know nfl pa didn't get them
under marcus where in time that's what
that's weird so demarcus where's 84
speed i mean he's a beast oh my gosh
let's put him on there yeah he has to be
a the starter at this point
jason williams is good on madden too
he's going to be a fast pace 87 speed
so we got two starters for our our
lineup just in this and you already have
so when you get stuff like this you
already have the patriots you already
are the patriots so
you can add it to your your uniform set
because oh so the sets are you're
collecting you just sort of set them
aside and they're not part of your
active deck yeah exactly yeah exactly
so once like that set right there is a
way uniform so once you get all 32 teams
uniforms together you can get you can
unlock something and it'll give you some
type of bonus
and every i mean every set just varies
on what they give you
same with coaches you can put them right
you can put them in sets too is is the
harbaugh as a set no no they don't i
don't think they have the hard was as i
said
hairy chesticles says unlock demarcus
ware's photo 99 cents
there's gilbert that somebody was asking
about so we got him
he'll be our starter
now when you play mutt do you find
yourself spending money every once in a
while or do you rely on coins a lot like
how do you sort of play it so i do i do
both i rely on coins but
i also purchase like when i see like a
they do like a legendary bundle where
last year they did
you get like
10 packs
and every pack has a legendary a good
legendary player and then
they give you one
like rare legendary player so
i spend when it comes to stuff like that
um
it
it's fun it's only you know it's a
little it's a little bit you know you
got to put a little bit of money into it
but
you can also go the free route and just
win by playing the computer challenges
or playing
um seasons which is they match you up
against people
that are of your skill level and you
beat them and you move up in the seasons
and you you get coins that way as well
i don't know what i did here i backed
out
i should well let's what do you say
about uh trying to challenge this guy t
dodd gatsby yeah yeah we'll try to get
into that game yeah does he have a mutt
team by any chance i don't know
do you have a mutt team
and you want to play my mutt scrub
league
that we've just assembled
we'll get the answer back uh
so are we pretty
yeah give me that welcome pack yeah they
give you that one for free i i didn't
even finish opening this is our
starters right here that
see they have trophies and you can why
would i even play i already won the
lombardi trophy yeah so you put those in
your sets
you get like
other the other awards what are the
other awards they give out
super bowl mvps yeah they give up yeah
exactly
exactly stuff like that the
walter payton
super good guy award
i'm trying to find the rest of my i know
we weren't done yet t-dot gatsby do you
want to play a mutt game or do you want
to play uh not mutt game
that is the question for you
tdot gas you would rather play head to
head but it's our choice so if you want
to play mup we can play mutt
yeah let's play with our team let's play
all right we're gonna play mutt t dog
gaspi so uh he should be in the friends
list he sent us a request okay uh let's
go get into that
and uh
we'll mut it up and we're gonna open up
our our last few packs first okay so we
get our our best see if we get anything
else yeah stack the dick stack the deck
we'll go pretty fast here throw it
through and it shouldn't take put in
frank zombie we'll put in lane for sure
all right that's fine
zombo i don't know if gilbert's starting
to
i don't believe gilbert
zombo i just like his name that's all
right we don't have to put him in let's
see who he's replacing no we can't
replace him with that all right that's
fair
sorry zombo
did he does he already have his mud team
great because he can start that while
we're doing this if he wants uh yes yes
okay or she i don't actually know
i could tell
uh archangel
can you assign the cardinals defensive
playbook straight to the garbage can
where it belongs yeah
do i did i have that right now
uh apparently not yeah you could
probably uh sell it right away not big
on the cardinal situation
all right
let's uh we're gonna go ahead and get
into a madden ultimate team match
shortly here on game spots now playing
for madden nfl 15 sponsored by best buy
i'm your host chris waters eric problem
taylor is the madden pro to my left
who's going to be playing against one of
the twitch viewers tdot gatsby is going
to be coming in here
and uh
playing us with his garbage mutt team
it's garbage munchie yeah
he's going to have all these good
players watch
you can never quite tell
we're almost done here um
there's only a few more i think there's
like two more packs that we got rex ryan
did i say eric problem taylor yeah
that's okay i meant eric problem right
i'm thinking like some friday night
lights action here
got coach taylor here with me he's like
my football he's my madden mentor so i
really look up to him like i do it's a
fictional character eric taylor
i just went with it you know
you can call me out on that dude
please
let's see i think there might be two
more
how's this mud is shaping up pretty well
do you think we're yeah we should have i
think yeah he's getting real nervous and
he says he wants to play head to head
but
kind of want to see the mutton action
yeah i mean
that's cool i mean
it's where everyone it's what everyone
is is you know transition into yeah
do people like start off playing mutt or
do they sort of grad do they sort of uh
gradually like as the as the season goes
on get more into it you know yeah i
think um
now it's become so popular that they're
just jumping right into it now
um before
it wasn't as popular but now it's that
all-time high right now and i think
people are once they turn on the game
they're going straight to mutt
all right let's do it yeah i'll uh so
he's
sent a friend request so we can go check
that out
yeah we're gonna get into a match here
with twitch user t.gatsy of course folks
we are broadcasting on twitch.tv and
also on gamespot.com so if you have any
questions for me or
eric problem right over here he's the
guy you're going to want to ask
questions too uh so again maybe go to
the unread messages
and uh we're gonna get into this with
t-doc asp nope that's an
xbox live preview uh so maybe activity
alerts because it probably
gatsby is your gamer tag the same as
your twitch username there we go
i don't know
maybe
yeah add friend and then
invite
pro versus
viewer i don't know what t dot gatsby's
madden experience is but if you want to
cheer him on
join us in the chat or the comments yeah
and we'll see how it goes
this
friendly little madden nfl 15 stream
straight for greatness says sick kobe
shirt probably oh thank you kobe's
one of the greatest you know
mccoby guy los angeles
what is that hate over there we got eric
tay in the back giving us the big thumbs
down he's a he's a big guy born and read
born and raised so not a lot of love for
the la sports teams out there
warriors or kings
that's sad he loves that golden state
much to his chagrin that's sad
all right so we should have sent the
game invite tdot gatsby hop on in here
uh check your your messages did you send
a no
it says no no friends online no friends
online you maybe got a friend friend us
back or something or appear online with
the friend situation
and we'll check that out
get into a match
a mutt match
i'm pretty sure yeah so you sent the
friend requests
yeah it should be there i mean and he's
just not not online i guess
t dot gatsby
go online with the madden situation
uh
while we wait is there anything else you
wanted to want to just sort of check out
or about
to go through the
the lineup that the way they have it
this year okay and it's
it's basically you know set up
so you can see the cards and you can see
who your
number one is number two and number
three
as far as everything goes your depth
chart this is all all in one right here
so my backup will be chase daniel
and then manziel is my starter and then
if you look at it wait can you go back
to qb one for a second yeah the third
backup
is like a punter
it's showing a punt position yeah so i
am not optimistic
then they're choosing the punter over
mark sanchez which you know says a lot
about
about mark right here oh no
and matt barkley they don't have they're
not too high on uh usc quarterbacks i'm
saying so
vicious we're gonna put barkley in there
as our third
i think that might that might be him
challenging yeah there we go okay
so let's just let's go do that uh while
we're getting into that match pack
wheezy in the twitch chat is curious to
know what are some formations this year
you're having success with blitzes
uh on defense the four six
and i i like the four four as well you
should have the invite i guess the
invites waiting so if you just go to uh
like hold down the that's going to be
the right size oh there we go
sorry say that again
4 6 and 4 4.
i've been messing around a little bit
with 3 4 as well
so i mean those those are the the ones
the main ones that i've been using
what's this
okay so that that's just i might have
had i might have some weird setting on
anyways oh
so this is the the
the only playbooks that i have right now
that that are active so
that's what we'll use and then
good we'll see
i'm not down with the giants man i know
that's that's the active one that's the
active one coughlin
yeah we'll see what they have i'm not
familiar with the
their offense or defense the defense
that we have bill o'brien yeah i know
what team that is yeah what team is bill
o'brien
huh
so we'll see
he has a we have the same overall team
overall rating for the most part so
we'll look at his roster right now looks
like bill o'brien is the texans defense
oh oh yeah that's who they they brought
in yeah that's right
that sounds right that's google right
there nice
yeah
internet
patriots ravens coming up here
yeah baltimore
wonderful tdot as a baltimorean yeah so
that's one of the things about mutt you
can
if your team is bad in real life
you know all mutt you know you can put
all the best players on your team so you
can live the dream yeah because you
might not be able to use your team on
the regular for with the regular rosters
they might not be
good enough
you get to see your team in action
or you know just play with your junk
team against all uh
really low difficulty yeah exactly
exactly never take them into all madden
mode
so once you're into this i mean it's
just a matter of
you sort of got to familiarize yourself
with the new with the playbook you've
got on hand yeah the well
typically i mean if we're going to you
already know the playbook you've been
playing mud a bunch you you know which
one you're going with exactly so this is
his roster right here he has blake
bortles
um
donald brown
is this like a little bit of scouting
you're sort of yeah you get to see who
see this is what i like to do i just
like to see different teams and what
they how they matched up the players
like he has sammy watkins
mike evans two rookies
um but again these are the mutt versions
yeah the mud versions which there can be
multiple degrees of sammy watkins in mud
it's not necessarily tied to the
actual
in-game it not actual madden official
rating yeah exactly
exactly so
if you have the the rookie version of a
player
he's going to be lower than the all-pro
version which is what they have a lot of
the time
they have the pro bowl version or the
legendary version
they have so many cards that they
release there's so many different
ratings for some players it's pretty
cool cool
a little bit of background on your
opponent tdot apparently tdot is an
abbreviation for toronto okay uh this
was pointed out by archangel in the chat
and also backed up by urban dictionary
alternatively it could be the tennessee
department of transportation oh okay
first down here i don't know if that
helps you get into the zone here
we'll see how it goes yeah so this is a
madden ultimate team game and once
you're in in the game it's playing out
like full game yeah it's just like a
full game of matter and um
if you're picking plays and you're new
to madden 2 you can use the coach
suggestions
it's just like what
what ask madden used to be for the game
they said that in the game it's now just
coach suggestion
and you can use that to help you decide
on what plays to use and stuff so
we'll go ahead and go with that since
you know we don't we're not familiar
with the shotgun
the tom
the tom coughlin
the tom coughlin playbook yeah exactly
johnny manziel fumbles on his first oh
yeah on the first series yeah he fumbles
and that's one of the things too on the
game it's it's kind of
from my first few experiences with the
game it's kind of hard to slide with
your quarterback right there i tried to
get down before i got hit i don't want
to get hit with my quarterback and
you know he fumbled so
yeah exactly you want to get down with
your quarterback if you can
um
wasn't unable to at that point and
fumbled the ball
a lot of people uh
not optimistic about johnny manziel's
season upcoming and so making some
disparaging comment today oh yeah i like
johnny
yeah yeah i like football
it's gonna be good hopefully make the
browns a team worth remembering they
exist yeah i know because they've had a
lot of down years as of late poor
cleveland fans
oh the pick
the pick over the middle
two turnovers to start this off now is
that sort of uh
do you
i don't know is that
when you're playing a mutt game you've
got a
variety of players that are maybe tend a
little bit lower than sort of the
ratings we're used to seeing do you find
that turnovers happen a little more
frequently or is that
that just kind of a fluke of you guys
both being defensive giants no it's just
i mean it depends on you know who you're
playing and
you'll you'll see turnovers here and
there i mean when you get a better team
though it's less likely like you're
going to make some of the bad passes or
you know they fumble as much
sure because i mean we both have low
rated teams at this point we're and
that's because the game just came out so
everyone's still building their team
and that's that's the fun part about it
too is you're trying to build the best
team
that you can
and everyone's trying to do the same
thing and you're all starting at the
same time so
yeah i mean that's that's one of the
cool things i like to do is you know i
want to make my team the best out of
everybody so we'll see sure we'll see if
that's and are there ever any
competitions uh for madden ultimate team
specifically that you know of yeah they
have um the mud invitational which ea
helps with i mean they sponsor that so
they do um they did like three
tournaments that that were all mutt last
year and uh
cam newton was that at the last one so
it's getting bigger it's getting bigger
i think that's where they're going with
them
i think that's where they're headed with
tournaments with competitive tournaments
is is
they're headed to mutt now in my opinion
so
just because they players invest so much
more time and yeah in their teams that's
their big you know that's their biggest
game mode and i think that they would
want to
showcase that if they had to i mean
that's that's where they're they're all
a lot of their fans are are headed this
to mutt
so right here is fourth and three go
forward on four yeah we're gonna go for
it on four
and don't worry there's a little bit of
a delay built into twitch streaming as
you know so there's no way tdot is uh
gaining the advantage oh god he's going
big for it on fourth down
daddy
can't come down with it
yeah it's again that's that's my best
receiver right now i thought he could
actually um
i thought he could beat him out actually
right there go over the top but i wasn't
able to
so back to defense pistol set here ted
no hands again
yeah he has he has had you know very bad
ratings as far as catch goes and i
noticed two right now with mutt
i don't know if he sent the regular
challenge but it's only three minute
quarter so i don't know if that's
standard if you can ask him that would
be cool to know
oh well he's probably not going to
answer at this point because he's oh
that would be on chat like right type
yeah we can check in afterwards yeah for
sure because uh or maybe someone else in
the chat knows yeah because three three
minutes kind of you know low for the
game he just scored right there um nice
work t dot yeah
so when you're when you're playing the
seasons and stuff it's gonna i think
it's
five minute quarters maybe
so that was it was kind of different
that it was three but um we're already
into the second floor yeah yeah i didn't
even notice that until right now i was
like man that was a fast quarter you
gotta adjust your pace man i know i
gotta i gotta step up on offense you
might have stopped too much made a
little bit of a different fourth down
decision yeah no or you still would have
gone for it yeah i would have gone
before i mean typically you you
you want to get the short fourth down
conversions if you can i mean
punting the ball
you don't want to punt if you don't have
to and uh unless you're like in a real
bomb yeah if you're if it's fourth and
twenty or something you wanna get rid of
the ball but
um
right there you wanna you wanna take it
yeah stops are are
not likely when you i mean as you get to
get a better team you're not going to
get stopped as much so you you can go
for more maybe at this point i should
have punted maybe that would have been
the better idea
around side oh yeah
the player seems so slow
oops
you got a couple of your buddies in here
oh yeah yeah rg madden oh yeah
sonic boom sonic boom yeah he's coming
in to mess with you
typical problem terrible on offense
just messing with you
yeah offense has been uh
i'm more of a defensive player overall
um
over the years i got better on offense
defense wins champions yeah yeah i mean
offense has to be good though to win and
at this point i mean it's tough right
now it's tough moving the ball the game
is still still new
and once you figure it like i said once
you figure out
how the game plays and what works you
get better on offense and you're able to
be more successful yeah you were
mentioning that at the beginning of the
stream uh you know sort of what
animations you can you want to aim for
what kind of situations are going to be
advantageous for you give in the way
that
plays in between player behavior has
been tweaked for the new version of
madden yeah exactly
exactly
and this and and like i said it's brand
new so
everything is is a learning process
right now as far as
learning what works and what doesn't
he's scrambling
that worked yeah oh also we've got ea
sports in the tweet here saying uh
mutt has three minute quarters but only
a 25 second play clock in seasons okay
well that's what that was rg madden and
then ea sports said yes head-to-head
seasons will be three minutes versus a
friend will be four okay so it changed
it changed this year which it's cool i
mean shorter games get them over with
quicker and
you get to the bottom of if you want to
lose quicker
and madden's been a longer game overall
i mean compared to like fifa
and that's one of the games i play as
well
oh yeah you get fifa as well yeah so you
get around the corner there and it's in
all right
go pats
so fifa games they go a lot faster i
mean they're online is like six minutes
but
if madden is lowering it that's that's
cool because you get more games and you
get a move up in the seasons and the
rankings faster so
i like that and crank through it a
little bit yeah go through it quicker
all right we got an even match between
eric problem right and twitch user t dot
gatsby who's been watching and
uh asked if he could play oh this is a
question i've had on kickoffs is
i see like a lot of kickoff returns in
madden
you do not see a lot of kickoff returns
in the nfl these days i don't think so i
mean from
from when i play and when i see other
people play they're not really common oh
really yeah they're not really they're
not really common on the game um they
used to be a lot more common
but over the the last few years they
they're you don't really see kickoff i
think i might have
had uh
three returns all of last year
in competitive games oh all right okay
so we've just been seeing a couple maybe
you saw yeah
fair enough uh are there any
does the game ever pause for like seven
minutes at a time while they check to
see if the player has a concussion no no
yeah
if he's injured they'll take him out and
then you bring him the back up in them
the next play is going especially you
know if someone's playing at a fast pace
oh yeah for sure
so we got third and three right here we
need to get a stop here big stop time
yeah i need to get those pressures on
t-dot
down
see if these pats could come up with a
stop see if bill o'brien's playbook is
gonna come in
come through
oh
that's an incompletion but uh i think
we're gonna see the going forward on
fourth yeah we saw earlier oh no maybe a
punt
we'll see what he picks um
right there punch
yeah he's going for it right there
they added that to where you can see the
previous play that your opponent used
oh okay and that's something that um
help you like profile them a little bit
yeah get a sense for their offensive
series or yeah you can just learn about
new plays yeah well what see what they
like to do
the big fourth down completion yeah he
got it
uh what are you saying
i mean you can see what they like to do
like i can see that play right there
wyatt trail
and you couldn't see that in the past i
mean
from a competitive standpoint i wouldn't
like to see i don't i wouldn't like
someone to know what play i ran on them
but i mean
i wonder if you can i wonder if that's a
setting you can sort of tweak yeah i
think it is i think you could turn it on
and off or maybe if you know because
this is a friend game you see it versus
if you're playing a season game
yeah or another mutt game you wouldn't
see it exactly so offline i i think you
can turn it off when you're playing head
to head
and then online if you send the
challenge maybe you can turn it off i'm
i'm not entirely sure
yeah
stuck him by the defense just gets quick
was his quarterback
blake bortles
my knowledge of blake bortles is that
his last name is fun to say
urdu 15. nice
yeah we got to get off the field right
here this is
oh he's going to pick the water down
don't you don't it's celebrating after
the swap celebrate the swat you could
have had that
touchdown
he's probably gonna punt right here so
it's fourth and fifteen um
we get the ball back there's only 18
seconds before half and
at this point
we can try to take a chance i guess
scoring maybe some get on the streak see
if he could get by everybody because
he's got that speed the other team
should be i mean they're
he should be fast oh kick this straight
in the air
i'm sorry he gave us a chance of getting
field goal range
gatsby must have his very own chris
waters sitting next to him doing the
kicks because we all know how that
worked out earlier
all right i'm gonna see again go for the
streak yeah we'll send get on the streak
see
if he can get by everybody
six seconds so and our kicker's probably
not very good at this point
so
you're not going to be attempting
getting it you know
10 15 yards is not gonna bring them to
the tournament that might be the time
it's going to be a 51 yarder
i mean
let me look at who my kicker is we might
be able to make what do we got who do we
got here let's see
we do have that backup our backup qb
yeah our backup qb is well he's a punter
i guess
see bullock i don't know if he's gonna
get the job done we'll look at his kick
power
what do you got for us randy
90 oh what you might be able to make
that 50.
so hopefully i could get good good power
on it
let's see
i still haven't gotten used to the
kicking either i mean like that they
changed the meter and stuff
and then playing against when i was
playing on all all madden the meters
faster like with the one you were
kicking on yeah like right now it's
going to be real you'll see how slow it
moves it's because it's on oh because
it'll be concerned i'm pretty sure it's
going to be slower so we'll see and
that's the thing i got to guess to see i
mean you got to see yeah when it when it
goes a week from now you'll know it yeah
pat no problem yeah the game just came
out yesterday yeah exactly so hopefully
it is
it is slow on that thing
that's power yeah
looks good
oh it's in there yeah
nice and done into the half
it's problem up 10-7 over t-dot gatsby
in a close game here on madden ultimate
team game spots now playing madden nfl
15 streams sponsored by bespot
what do you think is that pretty decent
announcer voice yeah it could use a
little work somewhere that was decent
that was good
so let's get a stop here and then
hopefully score
go up 10 10 will be
tim will be good with the the mutt teams
that we have right now it'll be hard for
him to come back from 10. you're pretty
comfortable two score lead yeah if you
get up to the ravens
possession
you can really see though the difference
in the player's speed
like right from right now from when i
was playing earlier with the niners
and that's what's good about mutt like
everyone is starting at us
a slow pace everyone's going to be
pretty bad and then so but let's say a
month in i mean you've got you've got
your team up much more substantially you
got a bunch more you got faster guys out
there but if i'm just starting my team
up at that point i'm still am i still
going to be placed the rating is going
to be around you know around my own
rating yeah you're going to be messed up
with people in so the seasons
seasons are um 10 games i believe might
be shorter this year and then you play
each of those games and then the more
the more you win the higher
the next level you go you go to a higher
season in the higher season and you
basically want to win the super bowl in
each season
um and as you win those seasons you move
up and you get to play tougher
competition as you move up so
um typically in the lower division
you're not going to see stacked teams
because those teams already move they've
already beaten that yeah they've already
moved up into higher divisions already
you just had a real good run right nice
run great solo
says i don't think i've ever kicked in a
football game it's either a td or
nothing
yeah and that's that's the mentality
you have to because when you're playing
competitively
um
you don't want it you don't want to get
stopped at all because the other person
is going to typically be good on offense
as well
so if you don't have if you can go for
it and it's fourth and you know less
than 10
i say you know go for it rather than to
punt the ball to them because it's
harder to
you don't want to just concede your
drive unless it's late in the game and
if you don't get it it's going to cost
you the game because the field position
sure then maybe you punt in that
situation but you don't want to do that
if it's going to
if you're going to just give them the
ball
early in the game you rather just go for
it and make them stop you mm-hmm
do you find your like madden football
knowledge and your like nfl football
knowledge like overlapping in weird ways
and clashing and you're like
football logic that applies to the
madden universe doesn't make sense in
the actual nfl or can you keep them
pretty separate no i'll keep them
separate um
there's some things in madden that i
think that you know nfl should do like
oh yeah like what i mean when you're
when you have short distances to go and
um in nfl
sometimes i see them punt the ball and
it's like
do you really not have faith to get one
yard come on can't we just just give it
a shot yeah and there's some situations
where i see that you know maybe they
should go for it in my opinion
and then sometimes i see bad clock
management as well in the nfl
from
i've seen it from multiple coaches and i
see it a lot more in college drop the
interception in college but
i don't know i just see it like my clock
management is
way better than some of these some of
these coaches you want me to come out on
sunday man i could be there yeah get
some calls yeah
yeah it's real bad sometimes some of the
clock management errors that i see some
of these coaches make um
you ever think of coaching like a pop
warner team like a
i don't know i did flag football i did
uh
my nephew's flag football team oh i was
underneath um
it was fun
i just you know i don't know
i know it's hard to get to the
collegiate level oh yeah yeah yeah and
all that you got to go to school
exactly so
you know
but i will i do critique them though as
i see it oh of course
i mean that's half the fun yeah watching
football is
critiquing them and acting like you know
yeah exactly i do critique though
you know some of the stuff like i said
is real bad so
you're getting some good backfield stops
giving up some passes yeah we gotta lock
it down yeah we gotta get a stop here
this is a big drive in the game um
he's running this why trail play a lot
to the
tie down wow he just got oh he just
crushed oh i wish i could see the replay
on that so you can see all my alignment
on the right you're getting crushed
no you know what this is one of those
situations where you want to let them
score so that you have like quicker yeah
we have enough because we have another
tough time
we have enough
right yeah we have enough time to score
here
but i do want to see that replay anyway
though and that that comes in i mean
that just shows you know at this point
my right side of the field was real weak
right there i just got
crushed all the way across and
that's cool that's the cool thing about
mutt i mean you see different teams and
different
play
styles does that give you then an
appreciation for the the good players
for the actual teams then like or not i
mean for the proper madden like
madden rated head-to-head outside of the
mutt yeah exactly yeah that's exactly
it's not he's not just automatically
catching that or automatically making
that tackle like there's a lot of other
options yeah you could get you could be
you could have this team right this
pastry right here couldn't have this
patriot scene
oh that defense yeah
you know in this situation i prefer to
think of this as they're like the real
word
real patriots last season it's not that
the players lack skill it's just that
all the skilled players are horribly
injured and can't play yeah like
gronkowski yeah yes
either they've been traded off to other
teams for a lot more money than the
patriots are going to pay them or
arrested yeah or arrested for horrible
horrible horrible things
oh
gosh
yeah so two minute drill right here we
got johnny menzel
uh we need to pick up the first down
first and then we'll move on from there
there it is yeah
i'm trying to get another big runner and
then
look down the field
jennings or again hopefully can make a
big play for me
140 left just
ultimate team showdown yeah it's
definitely it's definitely ticking
problem versus t dot gatsby
the weirdo patriots versus the bizarro
ravens
second and ten
came right through oh no no
yeah i couldn't afford to give that up
that was good
gonna have to make some
yeah there's some offensive alignment on
those on some cards
they came right through the middle
uh better center might be on our you
know our radar
we'll block up the maybe check out the
auction blocks yeah we can pick up for a
few
from the coins
brings it into his body
reader we got half of what we needed we
needed another 10 yards
down to it
fourth and ten fourth and nine
things are very tense here
baltimore ravens stadium
big fourth down for the home team
defense are the patriots looking to keep
their hopes alive in this preseason game
let's see how it turns out
quarterback yells things yells things
yells more things
he stopped yelling now the men are
running around in circles it's a throw
oh my god he just wanted it so badly but
that was that was to my receiver on the
left and manziel threw it to the right
that's that's crazy and that's that's
that's where the ratings come into play
and you can make those mistakes and you
can't just use
quarterbacks that you know are fast like
like i was saying you always look at
speed
you can't just do that this in this
year's version they don't want you to do
that they're focusing on
you know you should be able to use your
best quarterback should be you know
you're peyton manning and tom brady's
not
you know backup quarterbacks who are
just fast and that's how the game used
to be
um it used to be just you know pick the
fastest quarterback like michael vick
sure he's going to be better than you
know peyton manning in this game but
they're they're taking that they're
they're countering that with
you know stuff like bad throws like like
we just seen like
bathroom yeah they could have caught
that
could have gotten your cops a lot
you know that secondary still
yeah they got to work on their hands we
got to work on their hands so we're
gonna we're gonna
you know what that's interesting so the
it's really i mean it seems to me you
know that and you're just you're talking
from a few days of experience with the
game the
these new sort
emphasis on different quarterback
ratings working in these errant throws
in a way that's a little bit you know
that's different working in mistakes in
a way that's more developed than in past
years
it's really
you know it seems like
forcing you to be more cognizant of what
your quarterback's shortcomings are yeah
exactly and
they want to make it as realistic as
possible like
rg3 is not a better quarterback than
peyton manning
so that they want to get away from that
they want to figure out a way for the
game to support that exactly exactly and
making these errant throws from these
bad quarterbacks making that you know
happen in the game more frequently
makes it that way so where you don't
want to pick um
a quarterback that just is fast or just
you know can get out of the pocket
faster than anybody because that's not
gonna that's not gonna work like it has
has worked in the past oh i want to look
at some of these some of these
highlights don't like that touchdown
yeah good game
thanks for joining in and playing and uh
sticking around in the chat
uh yeah let's take take a look at some
of these plays here with when uh all of
your linebackers got yes romper stunts
on this play
everyone on the right side just gets
cut guard goes down breaks that tackle
yeah he breaks down this guy out here
just gets worked and then all 76 puts
the big
barely even touched him yeah everyone
got killed and then he did like a triple
lutz into the end zone
yeah and then this is um
the interception
i want to show like this is this is you
know a quarterback who doesn't have a
good pass passing ratings i'm throwing
to the post on the right on the left i
mean uh-huh and look where he throws
this ball he throws it you know way over
there to the defender yes way overthrows
yeah the post coming across and it's
right into this nest of defenders
regarding the player you were not
throwing to exactly sophie if i mean i'm
throwing a bullet pass so if he throws
it lower and accurate you know i could
catch that but
he can't make that throw because he
doesn't have the ratings and he's just
not he's not you know as good as your
peyton manning or tom brady so
it's cool i like it it's going to be a
challenge because
it seems like the broncos and patriots
they haven't been usable competitively
in the last
five years
you know just because
yeah because the speed has
a huge liability and um i think the
pocket passer is where it's at because
they did a lot of things on defense too
to make it harder for you to run with
the quarterback like this the qb spy is
really good this year
and then the qb contains as well they're
they're they're enhanced so
they contain you they they hold the
edges um better than they have in the
past
it's it's really good all around i mean
defensively for
to stop the mobile and then the mobile
quarterbacks stop themselves so
interesting yeah yeah that's really so
uh
so by the way tdot gap gatsby says gm
bro but we should get an h2h sometime no
okay yeah tell him he can he can add me
on xbox too it's problem right with the
x before and after so cool yeah uh so
yeah and now so problem if folks are
digging what they're seeing from you
know like your insights on the game and
uh and stuff like that because you know
you had a lot to offer today and you've
just been playing this for a few days so
uh tell them where where you are
streaming this on twitch pretty
regularly yeah um twitch.tv and then
forward slash problem underscore right
and that's right w-r-i-g-h-t
yeah my last name w-r-i-g-h-t
and on there you know i play
head-to-head
i do mutt um build my team
play against viewers different things
like that and um
i also have a strategy guide that's on
maddentips.com which is offered by prima
prima games and you know i do the
strategy you got um work on strategy
guys for them
offense and defense yeah so you guys can
check it out on there right on man uh do
you have any competitions coming up on
the on the horizon as of now there's um
the first tournament is in atlanta
and it's for five thousand so
i think that that might be something
that i attend and uh win so
yeah yeah yeah uh are these tournaments
televised usually no they they put it on
they have put it on twitch though oh
stream pretty well they have like
different cameras on different games
that are being played and it's it's
pretty cool all right man well uh eric
thank you so much for coming out today
thank you talking some madden nfl 15
here on game spots live stream sponsored
by best buy uh any final words for the
folks uh watching before we send them
off oh just build your team get better
and uh i'm gonna be building my team on
mutt so if you play me uh don't expect
to see you know johnny manziel out there
like this yeah
yeah my scrub league team is uh going to
be left far behind for the uh
the problem squad
what's your nickname for your team the
prop squad yeah
yeah we'll do that excellent eric thanks
again man much appreciated and thank you
folks all for tuning in to watch
gamespot's now playing of madden nfl 15
with eric problem right i'm chris waters
saying thanks for watching again and uh
come on back stay or stay with us here
on gamespot in just an hour our weekly
live show the lobby got game demos got
some more madden fun times and a lot of
good stuff for you in just an hour's
time hopefully we'll see you then take
it easy